bonjour ce jour là c'était le 8 avril
2003 et j'étais à bagdad pour couvrir la
guerre d'irak et c'était moment où les
américains entrés avec leurs tanks dans
bagdad et nous étions quelques
journalistes dans l'hôtel palestine et
hazard de la guerre la guerre venait
vers nice où nous devant nos fenêtres
bagdad était était empli de fumée noire
de pétrole s'appuyer on n'y voyait rien
mais envoyer ce qui se passait et moi je
devais écrire un article
évidemment c'est toujours le jour où ça
se passe que vous devez écrire l'article
donc j'étais à la fois dans ma chambre
au 16e étage en train d'écrire et temps
en temps j'avais à fenêtre pour voir ce
qui se passait et puis un moment donné
il ya eu un choc plus violent ça faisait
trois semaines qu'on se faisait
bombarder par des missiles et des baumes
d'une demi tonne
mais là le choc gelé senti en moi quoi
donc je me suis dit c'est très très très
très près et donc je suis descendu pour
aller voir ce qui se passait je suis
descendu en 14 au 15 ème étage pour voir
et j'ai vu des gens qui hurlaient dans
les couloirs des journalistes
je suis rentré dans une chambre et j'ai
compris que cette somme avait été touché
par un projectile
il y avait quelqu'un de blessé puis près
de la fenêtre y avait un homme qui était
un caméraman s'appelait ta race prod
souk qui était couchée sur le ventre
fut un temps où je travaille dans un
hôpital donc on va porter secours donc
je les retourner et quand je lis
retourner il est ouverte du sternum au
pubis
mais je n'ai rien vu rien du tout je
voyais une tache blanche nacrée
brillante et kim aveuglé et je ne
comprenais pas et puis la tâche s'est
dissipée et j'ai vu la blessure qui
était très grave
on l'a mis dans un drap avec les copains
on l'a descendue dans un ascenseur qui
s'arrêtent à chaque étage par étage
on a mis dans une voiture qui l'amenait
à l'hôpital il est mort sur le chemin de
l'hôpital et le caméraman espagnol josé
couso qui était lui au 14e étage et qui
avait été touchée aussi parce que le bus
avait touché entre les deux étages est
mort sur la table d'opération
quand je suis revenu une fois que la
voiture est partie moi j'avais un
article à écrire que je devais écrire et
donc je me suis présenté
je suis revenu vers le vert le hall de
l'hôtel
mais les bras pleins de sens et là il ya
un spear irakien qui m'a arrêté pour me
demander de lui payer les 10 jours de
taxes que je vais en retard alors je
l'envoyer paître et je me suis dit
surtout mais ça de côté
mais ça de côté si tu veux écrire il
faut mettre ça de côté
ce que j'ai fait je montais j'ai écrit
mon article que j'ai envoyée mais après
en dehors de l'affect du fait d'avoir
perdu des confrères y avait quelque
chose qui me dérange et je revoyais
cette tâche
une brillante nacré et je comprenais pas
ce qu'elle voulait dire
et là la guerre est passée plus tard je
me suis dit c'est pas possible je ne
peux pas ne pas savoir ce qui se passait
parce que c'était pas la première fois
pas seulement c'est pas simplement pour
moi j'avais vu chez les autres des
choses de ce genre en 20 ou 35 ans de
reportages j'ai vu des choses qui
m'avait affecté au 6 mai par exemple au
liban j'avais connu un homme un vétéran
il avait 25 ans 50 guerre donc c'était
un vétéran on le suivait partout c'était
quelqu'un qui rampait la nuit et avec
une sûreté d'un grand militaire un vrai
soldat donc on le suivait parce que vous
savez qu'avec lui on était en sécurité
et un jour on m'a dit et j'ai revu qu'il
était en train de jouer aux cartes dans
la caserne et que quelqu'un est entré à
côté qui l'a déchargé son arme que le
coup est parti que la déflagration le
simple coup de feu l'a fait se projeter
sous la table comme un enfant et
tremblay il paniqué et que depuis il n'a
jamais pu se relever et combattre et il
a terminé je les retrouve et d'ailleurs
croupier au casino de beyrouth parce
qu'il ne dormait plus donc c'est un
travail tout à fait adapté donc je me
suis dit qu'est ce que c'est que cette
chose qui peut vous tuer sans blessures
apparentes
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est cette
chose inconnue et c'était trop fréquent
pour que ce soit quelque chose qui soit
du hasard donc je me suis mis à enquêter
c'est tout ce que je sais faire je me
suis mis à enquêter et à fouiller les
livres les psychiatres les les musées
les bibliothèques etc
et là j'ai découvert que y avait des
gens qui savaient souvent des psy4
militaire
et que nous étions en face de quelque
chose qui est à on appelle un trauma la
mairie qu'elle appelle le ptsd pts 10
trop ma névrose traumatique que c'était
quelque chose qui existe et dont on ne
parle jamais et ce trauma qu est ce que
c est bien c'est une rencontre avec la
mort sais pas si vous avez vu la mort en
face je parle pas de cadavre parle pas
d'un du corps du grand père sur un lit
d'hôpital nom ou de quelqu'un qui s'est
fait renverser soit là sur la route je
parle de la rencontre avec le néant de
la mort et ça nous n'avons pas le droit
de la voir les anciens disaient ni le
soleil ni la mort ne peut se regarder en
face
l'homme n'a pas le droit de voir le
néant de la mort en face et quand ça se
passe
ça peut rester invisible pendant
quelques temps des jours des semaines
des mois des années parfois et puis tout
d'un coup ça explose parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est rentré dans le
cerveau espèce de fenêtres comme ça
entre une image et son cerveau qui s'est
logé à l'intérieur du cerveau qui reste
et qui va prendre tout l'espace de notre
cerveau et là vous avez des gens des
hommes des femmes qui tout d'un coup ne
dorment plus font des crises d'angoissé
de panique épouvantable de panique pas
des petites frayeurs qui tout d'un coup
ne veulent plus dormir parce que quand
ils dorment ils ont chaque nuit chaque
nuit le même cauchemar chaque nuit la
même image qu est-ce que c'est l'image
est belle image c'est par exemple pour
un combattant qui rentrent dans un
immeuble qui se retrouve face à un autre
combattant qui le visent
il voit le canon l'oeil du canon et ce
canon tout d'un coup devient énorme se
déforme
devient cotonneux avale tout est là il
dit après il dira j'ai vu la mort
je me suis vu mort je suis mort et à
partir de ce moment-là il lisse il sait
qu'il est mort ce n'est pas une
perception
il est convaincu qu'il est mort et ce
canon à soi quelqu'un arrive l'autre
s'en va ne tire pas peu importe il est
mort à ce moment-là ça peut être aussi
l'odeur de charniers les fugues locaux
au rwanda c'est peut être la voie d'un
ami qui appelle qui est en train de se
faire trucider pour lequel on ne peut
rien faire on entend cette voie et donc
toutes les nuits pendant des semaines
des mois l'homme va se réveiller en
transe panique et terrorisé comme un
enfant
j'ai vu des hommes pleuré comme un
en voyant la main image donc sur dans
son cerveau cette image de l'horreur
celle du néant de la mort qu'est ce
qu'on appelle la nana logo c'est à dire
une image qui cache quelque chose va
toutes occupées il ne peut plus rien
faire
plus rien du tout peu plus travaillé et
peu plus et mais il va chez lui ne
reconnaît plus personne il ne se
reconnaît pas il
ils se cachent irait chez lui s'enferme
je reconnais qu'ils mettaient des
petites boîtes de conserves dehors avec
des des pièces de monnaie au chaos que
quelqu'un passerait arriverez et tout
d'un coup il a envie de mourir il envie
de tuer il envie de se cacher il envie
de fuir il envie qu'on l'ait mme hillary
des tests des hommes est quelque chose
l'envahir du matin au soir et il souffre
le calvaire et d'autres ne comprennent
pas les autres lui dise mais tu n'as
rien tu vas bien tapas des sûretés aller
à la guerre tu reviens tu n'as rien et
ces personnes-là souffrent le martyre et
certains se suicident
après tout se suicider c'est mettre son
agenda à jour puisque je suis déjà mort
si je me suicide bon non plus je n'ai
plus de douleurs
c'est un suicide dow termine sous les
ponts se met à boire vous avez tous dans
vos mémoires
l'histoire de ce grand père de cet oncle
ce voisin qui buvait qui ne disait rien
qui était acariâtre qui battait sa femme
et qui a fini soit par son bras la
boisson soit par mourir et ils n'en
parlent pas par pourquoi on n'en parle
pas pourquoi parce que c'est tabou
on ne peut pas dire l'homme n'a pas les
mots pour dire le néant de la mort mais
les autres ne peuvent pas l'entendre
quand je rentrais de reportages la
première fois on me dit ah ils rendent
un portage et d'un dîner une belle de la
blanche des chandelles des invités tiens
raconte li raconté au bout de 20 minutes
tout le monde me regardait de travers la
maîtresse de maison avaient le nez un
cendrier en fait c'était une erreur et
j'ai compris qu'il est foutu la soirée
en l'air donc maintenant je le raconte
plus mais on n'est pas prêt à écouter
samedi à arette
est ce que c'est quelques canons c'est
extrêmement fréquents un tiers des
soldats morts en irak eu mort pardon
pour le lapsus un tiers des soldats
irakiens des américains en irak souffre
des pts 10 en 1939 il y avait encore
dans les hôpitaux anglais deux cent
mille soldats dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques anglais deux cent mille
soldats de la première guerre mondiale
au vietnam et 8 54 min morts américains
en 87
le gouvernement américain a recensé 102
milles deux fois plus en 2000 suicides
réussis de vétérans 2 fois plus de morts
au combat peu au vietnam
donc vous comprenez que c'est une
quelque chose qui couvre tous pas
seulement les guerres modernes les
guerres anciennes on les retrouve dans
les textes anciens s'est raconté s'est
dit pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en parle pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en parle et pas
parce que le problème c'est que si cet
homme ne parle pas il va à la
catastrophe
or la seule façon de soigner parce que
la bonne nouvelle dans cette chose là
c'est que ça se soigne le cri de munch
goya et setra oui ça se soigne
la seule façon de soigner ce trauma
cette rencontre avec la mort qui vous
si d'air qui vous glace qui vous tue
c'est d'arriver en parler quelqu'un a
dit les anciens disaient nous ne tenons
entre nous les hommes que par le langage
qui a pas de langage on n'est plus rien
nous sommes humains que grâce à cela
et face à cette image de l'horreur qui
n'a pas de mot parce que ce n'est qu'une
image du néant qui nous obsède la seule
façon de nous en sortir c'est de mettre
des mots de l'humain parce que ces gens
se sentent exclus de l'humanité on veut
plus les voir une veulent plus voir
personne
ils se sentent salle soulier ont deux
quelqu'un disait ma vous savez docteur
je ne vais plus dans le métro parce que
j'ai peur que les gens on voit toute
l'horreur que j'ai en moi dans mes yeux
un autre disait il avait une maladie de
peau épouvantable il a passé six mois en
dermato on se passer d'un service à
l'autre et puis un jour on l'a dit alors
qu'il aille voir le psychiatre
il a dit aux psychiatres à deuxième
séance il m'a dit mot épouvantable d'ici
jusqu'au pied dont il est dit mais
pourquoi est ce que vous êtes dans cet
état là et l'homme venu parce que je
suis mort donc je me décompose donc
voyez que c'est quelque chose qui touche
le plus profondes et des hommes pour se
soigner il faut en parler il faut
remettre des mots sur l'horreur les mots
de l'humain arriver à apprivoiser à en
reparler
il faut regarder la mort en face et si
on arrive à faire ça si on parle de ces
choses là à ce moment là peu à peu avec
un travail de parole on arrive à
récupérer notre part d'humanité et c'est
important
le silence nous tue ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que si après évidemment on
a perdu notre insoutenable légèreté de
l'être on a perdu notre sentiment
d'éternité qui fait que vous êtes là si
vous êtes là c'est bien que vous avez le
sentiment d'être persuadé d'être éternel
vous n'êtes pas ne vous serez pas là
vous dire à quoi bon et eux ont perdu ce
sentiment d'éternité
ils ont perdu la légèreté mais ils ont
retrouvé autre chose ça veut dire que si
on arrive à regarder la mort en face et
à l'affronter plutôt que se taire et se
cachait on a des hommes ou des femmes
que je connais michael du rwanda carroll
qui a calé de dirac philippe ii du congo
tous ces gens là que j'ai connu sorj
chalandon qui est un grand écrivain
maintenant et qui a quitté le reportage
après un trauma jeu quatre ou cinq amis
qui sont suicidés que nous n'ont pas
survécu
après des traumas et bien si on arrive
affronter la mort en face si nous les
humains mortels les mortels humains nous
savons nous sommes humains mortels
mortels humain
si nous arrivons à l'affronter et à
remettre sur elle cette chose qui la
terre la plus inconnu des terres
inconnues puisque personne ne l'a vu
si nous arrivons à mettre des choses sur
elle
oui nous pouvons mourir sur vivre et
revivre mais plus fort plus fort
qu'avant beaucoup plus fort merci